I lead the charm lab it's the Care
Health and reasoning machine in the lab
and we develop machine learning tools
text Jeremy Weiss PhD MD independent
investigator computational health
research Branch lhn CBC to better
utilize electronic health records data
for patient characterization and for
risk assessment
part of my work focuses on longitudinal
data that comes from electronic health
records so that we can do forecasting so
that we can know a patient's risk for
particular sequelae of disease forward
and time or we can at least estimate it
or predict it
another part of my work focuses on
Equitable risk assessments so that the
models that we develop have performance
characteristics across different
subgroups texts subgroups race ethnicity
gender or statistical likeness based on
risk of disease that may be of interest
we don't want the models to underperform
group
a third line of work is to better
understand electronic health records
data because electronic health records
data are a little bit different than
other types of clinical data medical
workers reviewing documents and using
computers and that they're passively
collected they're collected by
invocation as in the provider has to
seek out that information for it to be
entered into electronic health record
whether or not something is there is
makes the data incomplete blurt scene of
people walking not every patient is
going to have every measurement
collected and so we try to understand
how do we build models that capture this
type of data irregularity unidentified
patient data and various medical imagery
and be able to use it for prediction and
for characterization purposes
I think that better Healthcare going
forward is data based policy database to
health care and that's why we need to
develop tools and methods that help
utilize that data the best we can so
that we can make the most informed
decisions for patients NIH nlm grade
blue logo with underlying text serving
scientists and Society